- Hey everyone.
Thanks for joining. Good crowd.
My name is Monica Vyavahare
and I'm a senior technical
product manager with Amazon S3.
And I'm joined by Jordan Dolman,
a principal product manager
with Amazon FSx.
Today we're going to cover how customers
are using AWS storage
as they build and scale new AI use cases.
It's no secret that
everyone wants to build
with generative AI, but
the real challenge is how
to make it work for your data
for your business at a
cost that makes sense.
Today we're gonna show you
how customers are achieving
this all built with AWS storage.
The key to making AI work
for you is your data.
Generic AI gives you generic
answers, but your data,
like your customer feedback,
your usage patterns,
that's what makes AI
valuable for your business.
What we're seeing sets customers
apart today is the ability
to access relevant data
to fuel multi-step AI agentic workflows.
When your AI agents can get access
to the right data at the right time,
they can better understand your business
and your customers and
that can dramatically help
you improve your productivity.
So let's start with the core challenge.
I have a given task that I want
to improve productivity for
and I wanna use an existing
large language model or an LLM.
I wanna use a foundational
model out of the box,
but I need it to respond based on my data.
But here's the problem, LLMs
are trained on static data.
They don't know your latest information
or your business context
or your use cases,
so they give generic answers
and sometimes hallucinate.
So we're gonna discuss several approaches
on how you can build AI workflows
for your business using
existing foundational models.
This is where most people start today
because it's pretty
easy to go from an idea
and the data you have
to higher productivity.
As we cover different
approaches today, they're going
to increase in cost, time
and complexity, but they're
also gonna dramatically
improve in output quality.
So you can kind of pick where
on this scale which approach
fits right for your business.
Let's start with the simplest approach.
Prompt engineering.
If you have a single task in mind
and data odds are you're
starting with prompt engineering.
You give the LLM examples, context
and constraints to guide the response.
I can give you a personal example.
At Amazon before we build
or launch anything, we
start with a PRFAQ document.
This consists of a press release
as well as a series of
internal and external FAQs.
To anticipate what
customers are going to ask,
what are the hard questions
they're gonna challenge us
with after we launch?
This helps us work
backwards from the problem
to know exactly how to define
the right product shape
and build the right thing.
To help me make this PRFAQ
document, I have a saved prompt
and a markdown file that I use with QCLI.
In it I've included examples
so these can be good PRFAQs
that have gotten approved in the past.
Some big launches like you
probably heard yesterday,
some context like notes from my meetings
with customers so I
can specifically define
and hone down on what the
real problem statement is,
as well as constraints
like legal guidelines
from our legal department
on messaging do's and don'ts to include.
And the result, this has really helped me
with my personal productivity.
A process that used to take weeks to get
to a good first draft,
to get to a review point.
Now I get a something and minutes
and I get a reviewable
draft in within a few days
that I can review with
stakeholders and my team.
So this has really helped my productivity,
but how do I extend this
capability to my team so
that everyone can benefit from this?
Does it scale If I need
to include hundreds
of documents or multiple
different data sources,
I can't manually add in
all of that context because
as you must have experienced
the context window overflows
and once that happens,
quality tends to degrade.
What we really need is
to give the model access
to massive amounts of data,
but give it the ability to find
and use the only the most
relevant bits of information
so the context window
doesn't get overwhelmed.
RAG a retrieval, augmented
generation is a scalable solution
to this problem.
You retrieve the relevant information,
augment your original prompt
with that relevant context
and use it to generate a better response.
Remember, we're trying to
give these foundational models
access to your evolving
data without manually having
to load everything into the prompt.
So to bolster your prompt with RAG, sorry
to bolster your prompt,
we're going to use RAG,
which uses semantic search to
find and return relevant data
from any size data lake.
Here's how it works.
We start by converting
your data into a vector.
A vector is basically a
numeric representation
of your data that captures its meaning.
Once all of your existing data
is converted into vectors.
Next, when you make a
prompt to your AI model,
that query is also
converted into a vector.
We use spatial similarity
to search against
that query vector against
all of your other vectors
to find similar other content.
We then use those close matches
to augment your original prompt
and then together that
augmented prompt is then fed
into the model to get a better response.
This focused, relevant context instead
of generic knowledge that
the model was trained
upon helps you get more accurate answers
and it's also less likely
for the model to hallucinate.
So before you can start using
your data for semantic search
through RAG, you do need your
data in some type of format
to access to vectorize at
all in the first place.
And most of our customers
use S3 to ingest their data.
That's because S3 is low cost
and scalable to any workload size.
There are two main approaches
to get your data into S3.
One is batch ingestion
and the second is real-time ingestion.
Batch is a useful technique
when your data doesn't change frequently.
So think of documentation,
historical records, product catalogs.
They're not evolving all the time.
Another good reason to use batch is
if you need to pre-process your data.
You can imagine if you need to pre-process
like chunking or to generate embeddings,
this isn't something you
can do scalably real time.
The second technique
is real time ingestion.
Conversely, this is a good tool
when your data is changing frequently.
So for example, your
live social media feeds
or live transcripts from
customer support calls.
You don't wanna have a dated pulse
on what your customers are saying.
So you can't use batch
operation from a week ago
or every month that's
gonna have stale data.
You can use Amazon Kinesis
or SQS as a simple way
to ingest real-time streaming data.
It collects, processes and
loads the data into S3.
And there are also several
ways to do batch ingestion.
For RAG workflows, usually
batch is what customers choose
because it's simpler
and more cost effective.
Okay, so now we have our data into S3
and we want to vectorize
it so we can use it
for semantic search with RAG.
What are vectors?
Vectors are basically that mechanism
that makes RAG more powerful
through semantic search.
You can vectorize any type of data.
For this example, let's do text documents.
So you have your documents
and they're then converted
into chunks, which is
basically a finite set
of characters of text in this case.
Those chunks then go
through an embedding model
and some to generate vectors
and some embedding models
also attach metadata
to help refine your search to the vector.
These then embeddings
and metadata are stored
in a vector database.
Remember these vectors now
capture your evolving data so
that we can use it later
to augment your query.
There's several choices you
need to make in this pipeline.
One, you need to choose your data source.
So this could be an S3 bucket or a prefix
if you want more granularity.
You also need to choose
your chunking strategy.
So imagine you're a film studio
and instead of text documents
like we're doing here,
your data is movies.
You may choose to chunk by act or by scene
or some more granular timeframe.
Then you need to choose
your embeddings model.
And then finally, your vector store.
You can manage this pipeline on your own,
but we also have Bedrock Knowledge Bases,
which can manage it for you.
It has a simple way to
configure this entire pipeline.
And the nice thing is when
you're uploading new documents,
those documents are
already ingested as vectors
and they land in your vector database.
So now vectors are essential for RAG,
but managing large volumes
of vectors can be
challenging and expensive.
Over the last years we've
heard three main problems
from customers.
First is cost, many
traditional vector databases,
bundle storage, memory and queries
as a single together
making it cost prohibitive
to deploy large vector sets.
We've also heard that
scalability is a challenge,
so it's difficult to
scale from small proof
of concepts again to those
large production data sets.
And then finally, granularity.
We've heard that many
customers need millions
of separate indexes for
multi-tenant applications,
and once you start to get
to that scale, costs tend
to spiral out of control.
The real theme that we've heard across all
of these was cost.
Customers needed a more effective way
to store and manage vectors.
That's why this week we
launched general availability
for Amazon S3 vectors.
We're really proud of this launch.
It's the first cloud object
store with native support
for vector store and query.
And it has completely
transformed the economics of AI.
S3 vectors offers up to 90% lower costs
for uploading, storing
and querying vectors.
We offer 100 millisecond
warm query latency
because we're able to cache queries
that are frequently made and
sub-second cold query latency.
You can store up to 2
billion vectors per index
and up to 10,000 indexes per bucket.
That's over 20 trillion
vectors in a vector bucket.
And of those you can have 10,000.
We also offer fast ingestion
so you can get to work quickly.
You only pay for what you use.
And the best thing is this
is built on top of S3.
So customers get access
to the attributes that
they know and love about S3
like availability, durability,
security and compliance.
Vector pricing is fundamentally different
from traditional vector databases.
Like I said, most of them bundle
compute, memory and storage
and you pay for it all together.
You provision capacity upfront
and then pay around the clock.
The way S3 vectors has
changed that completely
is we've introduced three pay
per use pricing components
that actually align with your usage.
So first you pay for ingestion,
you pay for the vectors
that you're putting into
the vector database.
The second is storage.
You can leverage S three's,
industry leading economics
to store vectors at a
fraction of the cost.
And finally queries
you pay for the queries
that you're actually making.
There's no capacity planning necessary
and no infrastructure overhead.
And this is really useful
when your application
has varying workloads.
You can imagine during the workday
maybe your team is making lots of queries,
but at night there's hardly
any out of business hours.
This way you're only paying for
what you're using and
when you're using it.
Here's a customer example.
We launched public preview
of vectors this summer
and this customer has
been with us since then
and we've gotten to really work with them
and seen how they've scaled.
This is a biotech firm and
they've been using S3 vectors
for semantic search on
scientific literature.
Their team consists of PhD
scientists and entrepreneurs
and really their goal is to
discover the next breakthrough
in drug development.
To do so, they need to know
and absorb the large corpus
of scientific literature
and knowledge that already exists.
And this isn't just reading
a few papers every morning with breakfast.
The scope of this problem is
30 million scientific papers.
So before they integrated
with S3 vectors, this research
phase would take weeks.
And still you can
imagine it's not possible
to absorb all of this knowledge.
Since integrating with S3 vectors,
this is what their pipeline looks like.
They've ingested the entire corpus
of scientific literature
that they had access to.
Those were then generated into millions
of vector embeddings, which
now have landed in S3 vectors.
Now when they're exploring
a hypothesis, it's as simple
as performing semantic
search on these vectors
to understand what is
nearby and what is relevant.
This has dramatically reduced
their research timeline.
Okay, so let's recap
what we've done so far.
We have all of our vectorized data in S3
and we're performing RAG workflows
on it to get more relevant context.
But here's the thing, when
you perform a RAG workflow
on this data, it's searching
against all of your data.
We can make RAGs even smarter
with metadata filtering.
Metadata filtering helps
to narrow the search space
so your queries are faster, more accurate,
and more targeted to what you're
actually trying to achieve.
So for example, instead of
those 30 million documents,
this form could choose
to select only once about gene synthesis.
You can use glue to
catalog structured data
and you can add custom
metadata for unstructured data.
You can use metadata
filtering then directly
in line in your RAG workflow.
It's like adding wear
clauses to your search
to make it faster and more effective.
And here's where it gets really powerful.
As you continue to process your data,
more metadata gets generated
and this rich metadata
becomes the nervous system
of your entire AI operation.
Metadata gives you context
like what is the data I'm looking at?
This is Q4 sales data.
It also gives you lineage like
where the data actually came
from and how it's been transformed
and this has been really
useful for root causing issues.
And finally, it can
give you classification
like it can auto tag sensitive data such
as personally identifiable information so
that it's managed correctly.
Metadata helps AI understand
not only what your data is,
but what it actually
means for your business.
So far we've built a complete RAG system.
We've ingested data into
S3, we've vectorized it
for semantic search, we've empowered it
with metadata filtering
to make it more effective.
And we've introduced a cost
effective vector storage.
Many customers choose to stop here
because this is already
a very powerful AI engine
and it delivers results at scale.
But what if you want more?
What if you instead of
a single question like
what are similar scientific documents
to this problem I'm exploring?
What if now you want
to break down a complex
task, give it power
with tools and access to other datas
and then have it reasoned
through a complex problem?
Earlier I introduced prompt
engineering with an example
on how I've used it to
improve my productivity
with PRFAQ writing.
We are now entering roadmap
season for next year
and it's been great to
have many conversations
with customers this week at re:Invent
as well as over the last year
to help us define what
to build for next year.
Can I make a roadmap agent
using all of this information
and using several different tools?
What if I want customer
feedback from my notes
from this week as well as
product reviews we have online?
I want to check our S3 tables
for customer usage data
to find top customers
and I wanna combine those
to find the top pain points
that customers are discussing.
And I wanna write a PRFAQ
for each of those as a pitch
for a new feature that
we should launch for each
of those pain points.
That requires the LLM to now reason
through a complex task,
use multiple data sources
and tools and perform those actions.
RAG isn't gonna cut it
anymore. Now I need agents.
With agents, you give your
LLMA set of tools upfront,
things like Bedrock Knowledge
Bases for access to documents.
S3 tables for access to
usage statistics, APIs
to pull customer feedback
from social media.
And here's the big shift,
before this, with prompt
engineering, we had
to guide the model step-by-step.
Now agents figure out
the steps, figure out
what data is needed and what
are the right tools to get it?
So if we look at this diagram,
we were already prompting
the model with goals and
instructions and context.
Tools are the missing piece here.
This is all fed to the agent
who's using this foundational
model to perform actions.
Managing all of these tool
integrations can start
to get very complex.
This is where MCP comes in.
MCP or model context protocol
is becoming the standard
for how tools connect with agents.
It's really similar to
how HTTP standardized
how applications can talk to backends.
There are two parts to this.
MCP clients and MCP servers.
MCP clients define the how.
How do you query a database?
How do you search
through a knowledge base?
And MCP servers actually execute on that.
They check those
constraints and those rules
and then actually execute that query
and tailor the results based
on how you've configured it.
AWS is building several MCP
servers for our services as well
as external services to help
your agents find the right data
through the right tools.
For example, we have an MCP server
for Bedrock Knowledge Bases.
Now you can query knowledge bases
with natural language
no API calls necessary.
With this you can filter
to target specific sections
of the knowledge base.
It can configure the result
size and re-rank outputs
to improve relevance to
what you're searching for.
You can also do this conversationally.
So now my road mapping
agent can ask, okay,
what are the key limitations
that customers are reporting
and our product reviews
and it's all configurable.
So in addition to RAG
for semantic search, we
also need traditional ways
to filter and find data.
That's where metadata comes in.
You can generate and search
metadata with S3 metadata
and this works for both
structured and unstructured data.
So here's how it works.
Let's say you have lots of types of data
like PDFs, CSVs, audio files,
video files, you name it.
And they're all landing in your S3 bucket.
First you wanna configure
your source bucket.
You wanna configure S3
metadata on your source bucket.
Second, you wanna create
an S3 table bucket.
This is where a queryable
metadata table will live.
You can do both of these
through a single API call
or just a few clicks in the S3 console.
Finally, S3 will generate
a metadata table in
that table bucket
and it automatically
updates every few minutes
as your data is evolving.
It auto updates for new objects
that enter, it auto tracks system metadata
as well as you can configure
your own custom metadata.
RAG workflows can leverage this
data for metadata filtering
for more optimized and targeted searches
and you can also query it on your own.
For your own use cases.
You can use Athena, Quick Suite, Spark
or any SQL based process
to gain valuable insights
from your metadata.
So this is very useful
for RAG and for analytics,
but it's also useful for agents.
Now you have this rich cataloged metadata
and your agents can also access this.
This year we also launched MCP
server for Amazon S3 tables.
So now you can use natural
language to interact
with S3 tables and S3 metadata,
no SQL required anymore.
So coming back to my
roadmap agent, it can ask,
it can check the table of customer usage
and see who are the top 10 customers
for a given problem I'm solving
and what does their
monthly usage look like?
This is all available in
the AWS MCP open source
repository and it's really easy to set up.
Okay, let's bring this all together.
We started with prompt engineering,
giving your LLM examples
and constraints and context
to get better responses.
Then we added RAG giving your LLM access
to more relevant data to fill that context
and augment your original prompt.
We vectorized our data to support this.
We discussed metadata filtering
to target the RAG search
and we also talked about S3
vectors as a cost effective way
to manage your vector storage.
Then we leveled up to agents,
we gave our LLM the access
to connect with multiple tools
to perform complex tasks.
And finally we talked
about MCP, the standard
that makes it easy for your
agents to connect to tools.
This here is the modern AI stack
and it's where many customers stop
because it's really
powerful and it's scalable.
Some customers want to go further.
To discuss more advanced workloads,
I'm gonna invite Jordan
to the stage, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Alright, so Monica talked
a lot about how you can
use prompt engineering
to provide better structure and RAG
to provide more data to improve
the outputs of your model.
Now this works in many cases,
however, a lot of that data
and structure we just talked about lives
in the context window of your application.
That's kind of like the short
term memory of the model.
And because that's fixed
sometimes you have to go further
and actually embeds some of that content
in the model itself rather
than using something off the shelf.
So let's think about how models work today
and how they're built.
Every model that that we have access to
that's already preexisting,
has been trained
on a large data set and
the knowledge that was used
for training is now deeply embedded
within the weights of the model itself.
That data is accessible
when you introduce a prompt
to the model and get a response,
but if the knowledge you're
looking for isn't available,
if the structure doesn't
match your application,
then we actually need to
try to tweak those weights,
update the model itself to
get the right kind of output.
Now of course that takes data
and depending on how much data you have,
there's different techniques
that you'll be able to use
in order to actually train
and improve the actual
outputs of your model.
If you have a small amount
of data, rather than trying
to update the weights
across the whole model,
we really wanna focus
on just updating portions
of the model itself.
And if you're really gonna
get a big bang for your buck
with your data, you wanna
provide even more guidance
by labeling the data.
So it's very clear you have an input
and a desired output
that you're looking for.
You're trying to guide the model
to produce certain outputs based on
that small labeled data set.
And you're gonna focus it
on a small portion, a subset of the model.
If you have more data, then
you can actually still with
that labeling to provide
that guidance, expand
and actually update more
of the model weights.
That's kind of like, rather
than teaching the model a
pointed piece of information,
it's like helping it think in your domain
that you're working with that's
maybe not already embedded
in the model itself.
And then if you have
a huge volume of data,
you can actually skip
that kind of labeling step
and go straight to something
that's more akin to
continuous pre-training.
It's kind of like picking up
where the original model
developers left off
and then embedding that new
content in those model weights.
Now the services that we
have available to help
with this effort are Amazon
Bedrock and Amazon SageMaker AI.
If you find yourself mostly
on the inference side,
the application builder
side of the equation,
Bedrock is really where you'll
probably want to operate.
And if you think of yourself more
as a model build, model
builder, model developer,
then SageMaker AI is is the place to go.
In both of these cases,
you have capabilities
to do what we're gonna talk about now,
which is updating the model itself.
But each of these services
has really been refined
or tuned for specific
types of user experiences.
So let's go into some of the
different techniques we have
to actually update the model itself.
In this case with that labeled data.
We'll start with three techniques,
supervised fine tuning,
distillation and alignment.
And I know that there's
a lot of these words
that get thrown around in this ML space.
So one of the goals I have
today is to try to walk through
and make sure that everyone
has a clear understanding
of how each of these differs
and what it means for data,
what it means for storage.
Okay, so supervised, fine tuning.
Again, I mentioned before, labeled data
is really helpful when you're trying
to tell the model, here's an input,
here's the output I'd like to see.
So this is kind of in that same vein,
what is the input going to be?
What's the user saying?
What other context do we have available
as part of this exchange?
And then what's the single
best response or output?
Simple model maybe used for
something like translation
or summarization, that's
text to text, text input,
text output, might have label
data that looks like this.
Just a very simple, here's the prompt
and here's the desired
output I'd like to see.
This is a non-conversation model.
If you have some more
conversational models,
you know this is more of
like the chat bot type of experience.
You'll notice that the, the
labeled data is actually going
to need to have tags for the user,
the assistant kind of like
who's actually introducing
the prompt, who's responding.
And some of that labeled data
can also have multiple turns.
It can go back and forth between the agent
and the user as part of
that labeled dataset.
Now I should say the
reason why I'm putting all
this up here on the slide is
because when you're
thinking about the data
that you're generating and collecting
across your organizations, thinking ahead
to how this data might be
used can be really helpful,
especially if you aren't
expecting to be generating,
you know, hundreds of
thousands of data points to use
for future training, and
you're going to be relying
on labeled data sets,
thinking in advance about how
you might wanna label data
that's coming out of
maybe a call center log
or any other kind of interaction
can be really helpful.
Another example here,
different type of model.
This is image to text, but
we have an image reference
and then an explanation, a caption
that basically says when
you see this kind of image,
I'd like you to respond with a cartoon
of an orange cat with white spots.
This supervised fine tuning example
that I've shared today is
available in Amazon Bedrock.
So again, even though
it's intended in general
for app builders, you still have this kind
of capability available
to you when you're working
with Bedrock to customize those models.
The next capability where
you might be tweaking
the underlying model
itself is distillation.
So this is something that might be useful
if you're working with a large model
and you really like the
outputs that you're getting,
but the large model
isn't quite fast enough
for your user behavior, for
your desired application.
Maybe it costs more, but
again, you like the output.
And when you try to generate the same kind
of outputs from a smaller,
more nimble lower cost model,
you're not getting the results you like.
Distillation is kind of
like the cousin of supervised fine tuning.
So again, we have the prompts coming in,
but in this case you
don't actually provide
the output responses,
the outputs get generated
by the larger teacher model
and then get fused back
with the input and then used
as basically labeled data
to train the small student model.
So again, this gets a bit messier here.
I'm trying not to overwhelm
with a lot of text,
but the key here is you see
in this third row there's
this role of a user
and then there's some text,
some context and a question,
but there's no assistant
response and that's
because again, the assistant
response is gonna come
from the larger teacher model.
And so again, this is pretty useful
if you don't actually have
all the answers, but you know
that a large model would
produce content that you
like, you can use something
like distillation.
Alright. And then the third technique
with labeled data that can be
really helpful is alignment.
This is less about training for knowledge
and more about training for tone or
for maybe compliance, adding
guardrails into the response.
Sometimes this can be
something that's really helpful
for like the branding
of of an organization.
And similar to fine
tuning, we wanna provide
what's the prompt, what's the context?
But in this case we want
to provide preferred and
non-preferred responses.
And so this is where I think
the example is actually quite helpful.
This labeled data that
you're gonna be providing
also includes kind of a score or guidance
of different responses
and which one it prefers.
Here you're really teaching
the model not just what
output you want to see,
but how it compares to another output so
that it can really
start to understand like
and shape towards the
preferred outputs over time.
This is something that
if you were interested
in doing this kind of direct
preference optimization,
this kind of alignment
technique, you would need
to be shifting over to SageMaker AI.
This one isn't available in Bedrock today.
So we have three different
techniques using labeled data.
It's also worth noting
that the examples I shared
today are real examples.
You could use that kind
of structure and syntax
for supervised fine tuning distillation
and alignment, but they
don't work with every model.
And so you'll want to look
at these specific inputs,
specific labeled data
requirements for the models
that you're planning on
working with in advance so
that you're actually
structuring your data properly
or you can obviously
modify it after the fact.
Okay, so we've gone from the left here
through the labeled data.
Now we're all the way
on the right side, continued pre-training
and training a new model from scratch.
We'll come back with one of
those slides at the end as well.
(chuckles)
So here again, we have a lot
of data, we're not happy yet
with the output of the model
and we want to take it forward.
The best place to go here would
be continued pre-training.
This is where you don't have
to have that labeled data set,
but you can deeply embed
new knowledge, new tone,
new relationships between your
data into the model itself.
But the fact is, there are
also cases where the model
that you're working with
was actually trained on data
that is just structurally so different
from the model you're trying to create.
Maybe it's a different language
or maybe it's not a large
language model at all.
It's something like a
weather forecasting model
or a foundation model for drug discovery.
There you're really going to be starting
from scratch with building
a model and that's fine
as long as you have all that data.
And that's what we're gonna
be talking about here.
One of the big differences if you're
in this kind of continued
pre-training or training a model
from scratch, the big difference from some
of the previous phases is this
is a much more resource intensive effort.
And the integration between
your data, the compute
and storage becomes
really, really important.
And the reason that that's the case is
because getting all of that data
that we just talked
about, that vast amount
of data you need to train
a model from scratch
or do continued pre-training needs
to be loaded from storage
efficiently into your GPU
or accelerator instances
and then periodically
for a number of different
reasons, you'll also want
to write these kind of
intermediate checkpoints
back to storage.
Sometimes we wanna write checkpoints
because you wanna make
sure there's a safe point
to restore back to in
case there's some kind
of infrastructure issue.
And in other cases it
might just be a point
for you to evaluate the
model and maybe go back to
if you want to try training
with different data sets over time.
In all of those cases,
there's a lot of data
that you need to get into the GPUs
and there's that checkpoint data
that you wanna get off
the GPUs very quickly.
To give you a little bit
of a sense of the rates
that these GPU and accelerator
instances can process data.
If it's text-based models you're working
with, typically we see around
128 megabytes per second
for every GPU.
So if you imagine distributed training
on a number of different GPUs,
that number can get pretty high gigabytes,
tens of gigabytes per second.
If you're working with richer
media, multimodal models
or video, the throughput required
to actually drive data
into these accelerator
and GPU instances can be quite material.
The other thing that
can impact performance
is actually the size of the IO.
The size of the data that
you're trying to retrieve
at a given point in time
for a given request.
If you think about
reading data from storage,
the time it takes to get that data back
is a combination of
overhead for the request
and then moving that
data itself, the payload.
Moving or getting the request,
that overhead is authenticating
that you have access to the
data, it's the network latency
to actually go and retrieve
the data between the GPU
or accelerator instance and the storage
and then it's the metadata
lookup to figure out
within the storage system
where the data lives.
Now if you're working with small files
or small IO small objects, then the amount
of time you spend on
that overhead actually dominates the read.
And this is where having storage
that's low latency, storage
that is able to respond
and do that authentication,
shorten that network path
and do that metadata look up
really quickly can have quite
an impact on the job completion time.
And again, training these models,
doing this continued pre-training
or training a model from
scratch can be quite expensive.
And so making sure these
instances are kept busy,
that the training is
efficient, it's helpful
on the infrastructure side,
it's also helpful just
to GET responses to the people
who are developing these
models in the first place
and iterate quickly because
this is really collaborative
and iterative workload.
So within the storage
portfolio that we have
at AWS on the file side,
we have Amazon, EFS,
our elastic file system.
We have Amazon FSx, which is commercial
and open source file
systems that we manage
on behalf of our customers in the cloud.
This is kind of akin to RDS.
We have a of different
file system offerings
within the FSx family.
We have object storage with Amazon S3
and then we have block storage EBS.
For model training
in particular, the
shared storage offerings
that our customers use fall within the FSx
and Amazon S3 families in particular.
And then just to kind of
go maybe one step further,
how customers think about
which storage services to use.
Typically if you're
working on the research
and development side, file systems
are the preferred approach
for shared storage.
And if you're kind of looking
for something more optimized
for production use cases, data pipelines
that are more fixed,
that's where something
like Amazon S3 and object
storage becomes more optimized.
So let's dive into the file side.
Again, my goal here is to make sure
that you understand all
these different terms
that are typically thrown around with AI
and machine learning and
that you know which services
to use for each given use case.
In the case of research
and development, we have
different file systems
that have been basically built
and architected for specific use cases.
Scale up file systems,
file systems that rely
on a single server that can be larger
or smaller are one part
of the portfolio, one
type of architecture.
And then we have these
scale out file systems
that rely on multiple
servers stitched together
to deliver higher levels of performance.
Amazon FSx for open ZFS is
an open source file system
that we fully manage for our customers.
It's a scale up file system
that uses NFS for communication.
This is the most standard
way for file systems
to communicate with EC2 instances
or any other client instances.
And it's ideal for ultra
low latency workloads
like home directories, storing
your conda environments
or GIT repositories.
This is where your
developers are gonna want
to keep their data so that if you have a,
let's say a Kubernetes based
developer environment stack
where researchers are just
having their instances spun up
and down, but you wanna
give them shared storage
to work with in between something
like an open ZFS shared file
system is incredibly valuable.
On the flip side, stitching
a bunch of servers together
is how you get to something
like Amazon FSx for luster.
Again, this is a file
system we manage on behalf
of our customers so they
don't have to think about
what is luster, how does it work?
For our customers, this
just becomes a mount point
that you mount on your
instances and you do file APIs,
you open read, write close
files, very simple in terms
of the interface, but the
power you get is the ability
to drive very high levels
of throughput and IOPS
or transactions to your storage.
And so this is the
solution that we recommend
for customers to store their training data
to receive and restore
their checkpoint data
because it offers this
really scalable performance.
Maybe one example of the
type of thing we've done
with these offerings is
allowed our customers
to actually use some enhanced
networking capabilities
like Elastic Fabric adapter
or GPU direct storage
with our FSx file systems.
This offering or this networking
stack allows customers
to read data directly from our
FSx four luster file systems
into the CPU memory or the
GPU memory on those GPU
and accelerator instances.
And again, this is
optimized for performance.
This is why we recommend
these file systems
for these particular workloads.
And you don't have to take these steps
to use these networking
stacks, but they're available
to you and once you set
them up, you don't have
to do anything special to
achieve the high levels
of throughput that are actually enabled
by these networking stacks.
So there is one challenge
that has historically been
associated with file systems.
Many file systems are
based on SSD based discs,
solid state discs because a lot
of file-based applications
expect very low latency responses
and high transaction rates.
And one of the challenges
with SSD based file systems
is they can be expensive.
If you have large amounts of data
and you're some of it's hot,
some of it's cold, storing all
of that on an SSD based
file system isn't ideal.
And if your data volume is increasing
and decreasing quickly,
having the right amount
of storage on SSD discs to support
that data can also be challenging.
And for those of you who are taking on
that challenge and trying to move data
between hotter and
colder storage offerings,
that's just more operational overhead.
And so one of the things we've done
over the last year with our FSx offering,
is we've added FSx intelligent tiering.
This is very similar to the concepts
that we see on S3 intelligent tiering.
We have virtually
unlimited elastic storage
on our file systems.
We have that half a
penny kind of price point
that you might be familiar with something
like Glacier Instant Retrieval.
And then again, we're
automatically moving data
between hotter tiers including
an SSD based tier all the way
down to that colder archival
instant access tier.
And so for quite a while,
customers who were interested
in working with file systems
but had a lot of data,
they would do something
where they'd split their
data between Amazon S3
and their file system really just
for cost reasons even
though everything was going
to be accessed through a interface.
And so this really allows our customers
to just work with one single file system
and be able to take advantage
of all the different tiers
and get the performance of
SSDs for their hottest data,
get the cost of a frequent access tier
for their hotter data that's
kind of staying, you know,
really being used over the last few days.
And then as data gets colder
and colder, we archive it down
and you get that automatic
cost savings again down to
that half a penny price point.
So super easy and super simple
to work with if you've got
that mix of hot and cold
data and again, accessible on
that FSx for luster or FSx
for open ZFS file system.
Now if you are a customer
who has data stored in S3
and an S3 data lake, we
also have other capabilities
to integrate FSx with your S3 data lakes.
One option you can do is
connect your file system
to your S3 bucket.
You can load the metadata
so those pointers to your
data onto the file system
and they just show up as files.
So you open a directory and you
can kind of see your S3 data
on your instance just
as a regular directory.
When you go and access
that data, it gets pulled,
lazy loaded behind the
scenes onto your file system
and obviously communicated or shared back
to your EC2 instance.
If you add new data to S3,
it can automatically show
up on your file system and
if you write new data to your file system,
it can be pushed automatically back to S3.
So super powerful architecture.
For those of you who watched
Matt Garmin's keynote,
you may have seen this
architecture a couple of times
and customers like this
a lot because the storage
and IT administrators
can think about working
with their data in an S3 data lake
and the researchers can have
the intuitive collaborative interface
that file systems provide.
One of the examples that was
in the keynote was Adobe.
They work with this specific
architecture actually
to store a lot of their data on S3
and access it through a file system.
And they use this for
a lot of their research
to figure out what models are
actually going to be moved
into production, what models
are helpful and add value?
And eventually, they use S3 to do some
of their production training.
Now if you do choose to store your data
in a file system, it's
probably also worth noting
that we've added some new
capabilities this year,
in fact this week, to
make that data accessible
to a whole wide range of
Amazon analytics services.
So in the last example I mentioned,
you might have an a data lake with S3 data
and you can access it through your FSx
for luster file system.
In this case, if you have your
data in an FSx file system,
but you wanna access it with Amazon S3,
now we have this concept
of an access point
that you can actually attach
to your FSx file systems
and then you can actually
work to access data
that might be stored in
your open ZFS file system
or now in a NetApp ONTAP file system.
This is super helpful if you
are a customer who's maybe
migrated data from on-premises
with a NetApp file system into the cloud
and you wanna make that data
accessible to Amazon Bedrock
for some of that fine
tuning I mentioned before
or for that distillation use case before.
So all of that data is
now accessible to all
of these AWS services as well
using these S3 access points.
Now we've talked about using
Amazon FSx to accelerate
and deliver the performance
we need for these research
and development applications.
Let's talk a little bit
about what we've done on S3
to optimize for these
ML workloads as well.
So Amazon S3 has a lot of storage classes.
The ones on the left are the
ones that are gonna be used for
that hotter data, both
Amazon S3 Express One Zone,
which is all the way on the left.
And Amazon S3 standard
provide very high levels
of throughput for a bunch
of different applications.
Amazon S3 Express one zone
differs from Amazon S3 in
that it provides much lower latencies
and we'll talk about that in a little bit.
But really if you're working
on continued pre-training
or training a model from scratch,
you should expect that all
of your data is going to be in
one of those two classes just
because it's going to
be accessed frequently
and you're not going to want
to have the the request cost profile
of anything in those kind of
further to the right tiers.
One of the ways
that Amazon S3 Express One
Zone has actually optimized
itself for these use cases
is it offers lower latency
profile by not making
an authorization request
on every single GET request
or PUT request,
it actually uses a session
based authorization.
So you do one authorization
and then you can read and write
or get and put from your
object storage to get that,
that lower latency.
The other thing is in the name you can see
it's Amazon S3 Express One Zone.
So we've actually deployed
this S3 storage class
within the availability zone,
so it's co-located with your GPU
or accelerator instances shortening those
network paths as well.
And so those two capabilities,
that session based authorization
and the fact that we've
co-located the clusters
with your GPU or accelerator
instances allow us to deliver
that single digit millisecond latencies
that can be really helpful
when you're working
with small objects.
The other thing that
kind of goes hand in hand
with small objects is
having very high levels
of TPS out of the box.
So hundreds of thousands of transactions
per second available
with this storage class.
One interesting example of a customer
that's actually done a lot of
this kind of training working
with the S3 Express One
Zone offering is Meta.
They came to us asking
for a very high throughput
object storage class
that they could use with very high levels
of transaction per second
and very low latencies, this kind
of single digit millisecond latencies.
And so we worked with them to scale some
of our S3 express clusters in order
to meet this 140 terabit
per second throughput level.
That's 17 terabytes per second.
We are in clear super
computing storage range here
available in the cloud
to train these models.
Now I don't expect everyone
to be doing anything
near this kind of scale,
but it does speak to the
capabilities that we have both
for small scale and the ability
to scale to meet the needs
of even the most demanding workloads.
In addition to moving some
of the infrastructure closer
to our compute physically
in our data centers.
The other thing we've tried
to do over the last few years
is bring the APIs a little
bit closer to the workloads
that you might be running
with S3 for machine learning.
Two examples of that are
Mount Point for Amazon S3
and the Amazon S3 connector for PyTorch
because a lot of machine
learning workloads
and libraries rely on
and expect file interfaces
to be used to access data.
We added Amazon Mount Point
for S3, which is a connector
that's fully optimized for Amazon S3.
There's a lot of connectors out
there in the world that work
with object and provide a file interface.
We wanted one that was fully optimized
to take advantage of how
S3 works under the hood.
And so this is super helpful
for read only machine learning workloads.
If you're gonna train a model
and you're gonna read
through a lot of data on S3,
it's a very simple plugin to just say,
let me use Mount Point
for Amazon S3 to access
that data read only and to
just translate those file open
and read APIs into an S3 get effectively.
On the other side, there's also
some workloads where we know
that just swapping the
interface isn't sufficient.
When that happens, we wanted
to go further up in the stack
and that's where something
like the connector
for PyTorch comes in,
where we actually swapped
out the whole file interface
and develop something
that was really optimized
for Amazon S3 and allows
us to do more streaming
and prefetching to get data
from S3 into those EC2 nodes
for that effort.
Okay, so now we've, I think, finished
the whole spectrum here of
different ways for you to work
with your data to improve your
models, both for inference
if you're not really gonna
change the model itself
and you're just trying
to get a better output at inference time,
that's your prompts, your
knowledge bases and your metadata.
Or if you need to change the
underlying model itself, that's
where getting that labeled
data or unlabeled data
and doing some of the
techniques here, fine tuning,
distillation, alignment
or continued pre-training
or training your own model from scratch.
That's where that comes in.
More of the the model
builder kind of persona.
If you're interested in
learning more, here's a couple
of sessions over the next 24 hours
that might be interesting.
And then my speaker, Monica,
my co-speaker, Monica,
and I'll be off on the side
if you do have any questions.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)